emma thompson bonsoir alors soyons
clairs hillary clinton que vous venez de
voir sur ces images d'actualité c'est le
rôle que vous jouez dans le film pas
exactement
parce que le livre oui il s'est basé un
peu sur le primaire mais bon c'était une
trame ou si c'est une comédie c'est
fictionnaliser aussi et c'est important
se réaliser parce que le la presse les
médias veulent généralement se
concentrer totalement sur l'histoire de
clinton mais en fait ce film c'est
l'histoire d'une voyage vers le pouvoir
en fait l'opposition le plus puissant du
monde est alors pour moi c'était une une
vision pleine d'ironie plein d'humour au
plein d'humanité et très complexe très
ambigu ce n'est pas une histoire mais
chante ce relais clé clinton est ce que
est ce que vous ressemblez dans la vie à
madame clinton
vous auriez fait la même chose ou est ce
que vous êtes très différents j'ai
jamais rencontrées avec madame clinton
alors c'est difficile à dire
dans le film dans le film le caractère
que je jeu présenté à porter des
vêtements pénible s'est isolé bull le
grand problème beaucoup de nos landes
aude man made fable c'était très
difficile mais pour hillary clinton je
crois qu'il est beaucoup plus
intelligente
auriez-vous réagi dans la vie de la même
façon que hillary clinton face au
scandale au frozen amoureux si vous
aviez été les pousses du futur président
des états unis
oui mais je sais que vous voulez dire
mais il faut se rend compte que ces gens
se connaissent depuis longtemps et
probablement pensé du commencement d'une
relation comme ça avec un homme si plein
de charisme que le sexualité le libido
ça sa irai ça allait être ma main avec
pouvoir depuis longtemps alors peut-être
sakr du commencement que peut-être cet
homme ne seriez pas complètement fidèle
et on décide avec soi-même avec l'inde
que que c'est possible accepter ça que
c'est que c'est possible pour maintenir
et soutenir un bout plus grand si vous
voulez mais je ne sais pas parce que je
ne connais pas mais pour moi pour jouer
une rôle comme ça c'était ça que j'ai
décidé à faire et là problème bien sûr
c'est que quand on arrive de plus en
plus proche au centre de pouvoir
ce n'est pas une question de d'être
capable de se tromper de ceux de se voir
parce qu'il ya tant d autres gens qui
vont des monstres et qui vont des
émergences et emma thompson ce qu'on
voudrait peut-être c'est que les grands
hommes soient grands dans tous les
moments de leur vie
c'est possible alors c'est la première
fois que vous tournez avec john travolta
oui comment est il qu il est plein de
joie plein de joie et il offre
il en faut beaucoup de gâteaux et des
bonnes choses à manger les légumes ont
comme moi alors nous étions très proches
alors dernière chose je crois que c'est
votre troisième séjour à cannes 4e
quelle est la différence entre le
premier celui d'aujourd'hui
or on sait c'est cnt en angleterre en
chine
c'est la première fois j'étais sûr par
terre dans une chambre partagée avec une
amie parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'argent
c'était pour le retour à old and
alors mais c'était très excitant parce
que j'étais avec des grandes étoiles
mais cette fois je suis c'est un hôtel
du cap qui est
c'est vraiment alors j'ai fait un peu
d'effort c'est pas de blue jeans cette
fois merci emma thompson et bon séjour
dans notre pays mais en tout cas n'avoir
répondu à notre invitation au revoir
fait valoir